the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
all right my friends there is some
breaking news regarding many shows in
the
song of ice and fire cinematic universe
that is in development at hbo
now just in case some of you have been
living under a rock hbo has been
developing a lot of new ideas that will
be based on george rr martin's work
as you all know game of thrones is one
of the most successful
shows ever created i have even seen some
estimates that say game of thrones made
hbo billions of dollars which is
absolutely insane
now that hbo is fighting netflix amazon
hulu
and disney for subscribers they are
hoping they can create their own
cinematic universe that will be set
within the world of a song of ice and
fire
they started developing other shows
before game of thrones ended
as of right now house of the dragon is
their only other show that has been
given a full series order
most of you should know they have
already begun filming its first season
house of the dragon will most likely air
its first episode in the first half of
next year
so just in case any of you were
wondering house of the dragon is safe
the show has not been shut down in any
way i don't think it will be either
hbo has hired some of the best in the
business to help them get this show off
the ground and i believe it will be
another one of their successful shows
that runs for many many seasons in the
future
i wanted to make sure everyone
understood that before i go any further
house of the dragon is still moving full
steam ahead
don't let anyone else say otherwise now
one of their new ideas that has just
been cancelled is the series about flea
bottom
the fictional slums of king's landing
some of you may remember
hbo announced very recently they were
developing three other shows
one of them was about nymeria the other
series is about the nine voyages of
coreless velaryon
and the third series was flea bottom
which is no longer in development
now i'm not exactly sure why they shut
down flea bottom but the idea was in the
very early stages of development anyway
so it seems the show did not have enough
to keep the network
interested as i'm sure most of you know
this is not the first time hbo has
canceled a game of thrones successor
show since the main series ended
they were also once developing a show
about the long night
that was set roughly 8 000 years before
the main events of game of thrones
the series about the long night was
going to show the white walker's origin
story as well as some of westeros's dark
secrets
they even shot a pilot episode for the
series but it must have been really bad
because they shut everything down
shortly
after that flea bottom did not even make
it that far
now i do have some good news as well
although hbo has cancelled flea bottom
they did order two more animated
spin-off shows
according to hollywood reporter hbo max
is now developing
three animated game of thrones spin-offs
for the streaming service
at least one of those will be set in the
golden empire of yiti
while never explicitly shown in game of
thrones yiti
is said to be one of the oldest and most
advanced societies in george r martin's
fantasy world
and is inspired by imperial china this
region is said to have more cities than
any other land in the known world
and according to lomas longstrider they
are much larger and more splendid than
cities in the west
this could make for a very interesting
show and since it would be set in essos
it would make for a much more diverse
cast of characters as well
now the details on the other recently
ordered animated shows have not been
revealed
as of yet if i do find out any more
information i will let you know right
away
for now i will keep this video short and
sweet i just wanted to make sure you
were all
up to date on any news surrounding game
of thrones and a song of ice and fire as
always i want to thank all of you for
watching the video
i hope you have a great day i will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
you